art for clark county students in one
week and this semester we want your kids
to have a box lunch with a bang so here
to show us how is our friend jessica wu
the bento box queen it's great to see
you hey thank you for having me we love
it when you're on the show you have a
huge tick tock following a huge
instagram following uh you create pieces
of art is what you do when it comes to
these bento boxes and today you're going
to start off by showing us some of the
tools that you guys use what do you have
here so i have some of my new lunchboxes
i have ready for the school year
they're
you know they're all different i like
switching them up depending on what i'm
using so you can kind of look i also
like to use this kind of thermos
container a lot of people are like what
do you use to keep things warm um soups
anything like that because i remember
taking soup as a kid to school and i
would get there and i pop over my
thermos here in the 80s and the soup
would be cold yeah so this stays warm
yeah it's good it gets day one
if it's turkey and what are you getting
and what are these little couches and
where are you buying all this stuff so i
have um i usually just buy them anywhere
i can find them amazon target walmart
nowadays you know you can find a lot of
lunch accessories i don't know if it's
because of me but um i have my amazon
storefront too i can give you guys a
little please do yeah so i link it
everywhere these are little fun
food cutters so i use these for
food like fruit anything that's kind of
flat i can kind of show you an example
over here with cheese
so
these just kind of make fun of you make
lunch fun which i love about you so just
like that
you know this just goes a long way it
does it's the same cheese but in a
little shape it's fun i want to eat that
cheese you make it fun
so we have different kinds of shapes
here i have this egg mold this is a
little bit fun too you just stick in a
hard-boiled egg i have one made over
here are you kidding me with this one
yeah pop everything open i added a
little soy sauce oh yeah it just kind of
adds in a little
shape and it's just a hard-boiled egg
right here look at this thing
look at that if you're a child you would
want to eat that right away right
okay you have notes too because which i
love yeah what how many kids three kids
i have three kids and you always put
little little notes with the girls when
they go to school yeah so i found these
at hallmark they're tiny little cards
and they have cute little things and i
just write them you know hey i'm missing
you whatever it is you know
encouragement put that in the nuts i
also like using scissors for cutting any
food a lot of people don't think that
you can use scissors in the kitchen but
i use it for cutting anything okay let's
go can we assemble one can i see you i
create some art here yeah
we'll use this guy all right so we're
gonna make one of my girls favorite
lunches it's
kind of like a traditional korean type
lunch so i have rice i made some wontons
and you made it all in advance
yeah you suggest making this stuff in
advance you can assemble in the morning
and send you off you said you know what
you can buy frozen wontons they sell
them pretty much anywhere whole foods
traders
i just steam these in my airfryer it
kind of has that all in one function um
for nine minutes so i just pop this in
you know if i need to get ready in the
morning do that and then they're ready
to go so you can prep in the more or
prep at night if you don't have time but
i like to do things in the morning
because it's fresher sure so what are
you gonna put in there all right so
let's add the wontons here so you can do
it you see
okay how many wontons go in the box i
wash my hands but it's also my kids i
feel like i might use my kids right more
flavor yeah okay
so one thumbs here i'm gonna you can add
a little bit do use your hands or try to
be hygienic and use a spoon you know i
use my hands whatever it works you know
tools of the trade so we get some rice
yeah rice in there
all right we can also here i'm going to
show you one of my favorite tools
um put a little bit of rice on each all
right use my hands here just a little
bit and this is an amazon find yes all
right so this makes your rice into
little balls
so you're going to shake this up shake
it like this
sideways
vertical horizontal
put
my mom every day i love her she watches
the show every day she would make me an
egg salad sandwich every single day for
the first two years of school so i
finally said mom enough egg salad
sandwich i love it but please i need
something different you know parents do
that a lot if you tell them what you
like they want to make it for you until
every day okay oh my gosh i wish i had
bento boxes okay what else is going on
okay so this is roasted and salted
seaweed and by the way look at i mean
the rice this is so cool yeah it's just
you know it's fun
and then i'm just gonna add seaweed and
i'm just using my scissors
in there so my girls like to just wrap
the seaweed with the balls and eat it
together kind of like sushi
and then we're going to add in some
fruits when you're preparing this are
you thinking as go ahead and put the
fruit in but you're thinking i want to
make this a square meal for my child
some protein some fruits and veggies and
everything else right yeah and that was
like the biggest part of decorating was
like hey how can i make it more
nutritional because they you know
they're like regular kids they don't
like they don't like veggies so you know
if i cut into a little flower i'd be
like hey can you just try it at least
you know and they see the effort i put
into it and they're like okay mom made
this she took her time okay i'm gonna
try it you know so that's just i love it
that's what i do jessica you're you're
it's always fantastic when you come on
the show we have so much more to show
but i do have to wrap things up here if
someone's watching right now they want
to follow you on social media tick-tock
everything else how do they find you um
it's sully jessica my first and middle
name
s-u-l-a-t-e j-s-s-i-c-a i love it we're
going to tag you today on all social
media thank you so much clark county
school starts in less than a week you're
making back to school lunch is fun thank
you so much jessica las vegas now we
will be right back